it was a cold
sunny march day i was walking along the
street in riga
i remember the winter was slowly coming
to an end
there was still some snow around here
and there but the pavement was already
clear and dry if you've lived in riga
you'll know that feeling of relief
that the first signs of spring bring
and you no longer have to trudge through
that slushy mix of snow and mud on the
streets
so there i am enjoying my stroll
as i suddenly notice a stencil
on the pavement in front of me a
graffiti
white letters painted on these dark gray
bricks
it says where is
your responsibility
the question stopped me in my tracks
as i'm standing there considering its
meaning
i notice i'm standing outside the riga
municipality social welfare department
so it appears that the author of this
graffiti whoever it is
is asking this question to people coming
to apply for social assistance
that winter i had been doing research on
the aftermath
of the financial crisis in latvia when
the global financial crisis erupted in
latvia got hit hard as a small open
economy
to balance the books the latin
government chose a strategy of internal
devaluation now in essence that meant
drastically reducing public budget
spending so
slashing public sector workers wages
shrinking civil service
cutting unemployment benefits and other
social assistance
raising taxes my mother had been working
as a history teacher her whole life
the austerity for her men seeing her
salary
cut by 30 all of a sudden
and there were many in a situation like
hers or worse
the costs of the crisis were put on the
shoulders of ordinary
latvians as a result of the
crisis and the austerity the latvian
economy shrunk by 25
in a two-year period only greece
suffered an economic contraction of a
comparable scale
yet while greeks were out on the streets
for months staging continues often
violent protests in athens
all was quiet in riga
prominent economists for fighting in the
columns of new york times about this
curious extreme
latvian experiment of this austerity
regime
and they were watching on in this belief
how the latvian society was putting up
with it
i was studying in london at the time and
i remember the occupy movement there
and how it was spreading from city to
city from madrid to new york to london
the 99 against the one percent you know
the story
yet when i arrived in riga there were no
echoes of the occupy here
latvians were just putting up with it
they swallowed the toad as the local
saying goes
for my doctoral research i wanted to
study how the state citizen relationship
was changing
in latvia in the post-soviet era and i
chose an
unemployment office as my research site
and as i arrived there in that autumn of
2011 i realized
i'm actually witnessing firsthand how
the effects of crisis are playing out
and how those worst affected by it
people who have lost their jobs
are reacting to it
so i started interviewing people i met
at the unemployment office
they were all registered as job seekers
and hoping for some help from the state
yet as i was soon discovering this help
was of a particular kind
there was some cash benefit but mostly
state assistance came in the form of
various social programs
and one of the biggest of these programs
was called competitiveness raising
activities
it was in essence a series of seminars
that all of the unemployed were
encouraged to attend
so i started attending these seminars
with them
and a number of paradoxes struck me
so imagine the crisis is still
ongoing the latvian economy is
contracting
hardly anyone is hiring and there we are
in this small brightly lit classroom a
group of 15 people
working on lists of our personal
strengths and weaknesses
our inner demons that we're told are
preventing us from being more successful
in the labor market
as the largest local bank is being
bailed out and the costs of this bailout
are shifted onto the shoulders of the
population
we are sitting in a circle and learning
how to breathe
deeply when feeling stressed
as home mortgages are being foreclosed
and thousands of people are emigrating
we are told to dream big and to follow
our dreams
as a sociologist i know that social
policies are an important form of
communication
between the state and the citizen the
message of this program was
to put it in the words of one of the
trainers just do it
she was a force setting nike so
symbolically
the state was sending a message to
people out of work that
you need to be more active you need to
work harder
you need to work in yourself you need to
overcome your inner demons you need to
be more confident
that somehow being out of work was their
own personal failure
the suffering of the crisis was treated
as this individual experience of stress
to be managed in one's own body through
deep and mindful breathing
these types of social programs that
emphasize individual responsibility have
become increasingly common across the
world
they are part of the rise of what
sociologist louis wakan calls
the neoliberal centaur state now the
centaur as you might recall
is this mythical creature an ancient
greek culture half human have beast
it has this upper part of a human in the
lower
part of a horse so the centaur state
is a state that turns its human face to
those at the top of the social ladder
while those at the bottom are being
trampled over
stampeded so top income earners and
large businesses can enjoy tax cuts and
other supportive
policies while the unemployed the poor
are made to prove themselves worthy for
the state's help
are morally disciplined are stigmatized
as irresponsible or passive or lazy are
often criminalized
in latvia we've had such a center state
model
firmly in place since the 90s take for
example the flat income tax
that we had in place up until this year
that has been benefiting the highest
earners
while one quarter of the population
keeps living in poverty
and the crisis has and the austerity has
made these kinds of social inequalities
worse so while the capital of the banks
and the wealthy has been protected
those who lost the most were taught
lessons in individual responsibility
now as i was talking to people who i met
at these seminars i was expecting them
to be angry
i was expecting them to be resisting
these lessons in individual
responsibility after all the crisis was
not their fault
yet they were bearing the brunt of it
but
as people were sharing their stories
with me i was struck
again and again by the power of the idea
of responsibility one of the people
i met was jonathan
she had been working for 23 years
teaching
sewing and other crafts at the
vocational school in riga
now the crisis hits and the school is
closed
as part of the austerity measures the
educational system restructuring was
part of a way of
saving public money and 10 000 teachers
across the country lose their jobs and
janet is one of them
and i know from what she's been telling
me that losing her job has put her in a
desperate situation she's divorced she
has two tina children that she's the
sole provider for
and yet as we're talking she says to me
that the crisis is really an opportunity
she says i turned 50 this year
i guess life has really given me this
chance to look around
to stop because all these years i've
been working non-stop had no time to
pause
and now i have stopped and i've been
given an opportunity to look at
everything and to decide
what it is that i want and what it is
that i don't want
all this time sewing sewing some kind of
exhaustion
so jeanette is made redundant after 23
years
but she's not thinking about protesting
she's not talking about the 99 percent
against the one percent
she is analyzing herself and she was
thinking pragmatically of starting a
small business out of her bedroom
uh making these little souvenir dolls to
sell to tourists
i also met ivers at the unemployment
office ivers was in his late 40s
he had lost a job at the government
agency overseeing
road construction to one of our meetings
ivers brings a book he's been reading
it's called
vaccination against stress or
psycho-energetic aikido now
some of you might know that aikido is a
form of martial arts so
psycho-energetic aikido
and iris tells me that after several
months of reading and thinking and
reflecting
while being out of work he has
understood
that his current difficulties are really
his own
doing he says to me i created it myself
i was in a psychological state that was
not good for me
if a person is afraid to lose their
money to lose their job
they start getting more stressed more
unsettled more fearful that's what they
get
as i ask him to explain he compares his
thoughts poetically to wild horses
running in all directions and he says
you need to be a shepherd of your
thoughts
to get things in order in the material
world you need to be a shepherd of your
thoughts because it's through the
thoughts that everything else gets
orderly
lately he says i have clearly understood
that the world around me
what happens to me people that enter my
life it all depends directly on myself
so as latvia is going through this
extreme economic experiment
ivor says it's his way of thinking that
has to change
he's blaming himself for what is what
he's going through at the moment
so taking responsibility is of course a
good thing
right it is especially meaningful and
morally charged in a post-soviet society
where reliance on the state is seen as
this unfortunate heritage of the soviet
past
but when i listened to jonathan ivers
and to others i also thought
how cruel this question is where is your
responsibility
how punishing because it was working as
a way of blaming and pacifying people
who were
hit worse by the crisis so while greeks
were out on the streets latvians
swallowed the toad
and many tens of thousands emigrated
which is another way of taking
responsibility
so the language the language of
individual responsibility has become a
form of collective denial
as long as we have social policies that
treat unemployment as
individual failure but we don't have
enough funding for programs that
give people real skills or create
workplaces we are blind of the
policymaker's responsibility
as long as we stigmatize the poor as
somehow passive or lazy
but don't give people real means to get
out of poverty other than emigrating
we are in denial of the true causes of
poverty
and in the meantime we all suffer
because social scientists have shown
with detailed statistical data
that there are more people with both
mental and physical health problems
in societies with higher levels of
economic inequality
so social inequality is apparently bad
for not only those with
least resources but for all of us
because living in a society was high in
equality means
living in a society with low social
trust and high anxiety
so there we are we're all reading
self-help books
we try to hack our habits we try to
rewire our brains we meditate
and it helps of course in a way
self-help books help us feel more upbeat
meditation
can help us feel more connected to
others spiritually
what i think we need is as much
awareness of what connects us to one
another
socially because social inequality hurts
us all
so we need more compassionate social
policies
that are aimed less at moral education
and more at promotion of social justice
and equality thank you
you